we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p now there are
people who like the david pakman show
intro theme song and there are people
who don't like the david pakman show
intro theme song what i have for you
today is a candidate for replacing our
current theme song a viewer called in
who has just a beautiful beautiful voice
and sang what could be a replacement
david pakman show theme song for us
let's take a listen and let me know if
you like this better than what we're
currently using the david pakman show
it's my favorite show you do more good
than you know the david pakman show yeah
so listen in all seriousness if someone
can make either like an EDM or a dubstep
remix of that to quote Donald Trump from
when he asked Russia to hack Hillary's
emails I think you would be greatly
rewarded for that with audience audience
karma so to speak please please please
consider if you have the skills and I
know that many people in our audience do
consider doing an EDM or dubstep remix
of that and send it to me I would love
it and I think it would definitely make
its way onto the show on today's bonus
show we are going to talk about what
Texas is doing to gun laws right after
we've had more mass shootings including
one in Texas what they are doing is as
as would you have a whole bunch of
people in the in the country who want to
tighten up gun laws as a result of the
mass shootings that we're having Texas
is actually set to loosen their gun laws
interestingly enough so we'll talk about
that on the bonus show we will also talk
about different day time schedules it
there's a new study which says that one
in 300 people truly thrive on a very
early to bed very early to rise routine
now there are lots of people who have
adopted that schedule early to bed early
to rise but you can't really say that
they're thriving in fact it's really a
struggle one in 300 appear
actually thrive on that and we'll talk
about who they are and then lastly
there's a lawmaker who wants to curb
social media addiction with a new bill
and of course there are questions about
is this nanny state liberals trying to
control us is this suppression of speech
of some kind all of those things that
you would anticipate are being discussed
we will talk about the text of the
proposal we will talk about its merits
and much much more
two ways to get access to the bonus show
become a member or become a patron
become a member at WWE at medCom or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show both will give you
instant access to the bonus show and
lastly the newest thing we're doing
please follow me on twitch at twitch.tv
slash david pakman follow me there we've
built up almost 10,000 subscribers just
in our first week on Twitch which is
unbelievable and if you have an Amazon
Prime membership you can subscribe to
twitch Prime Amazon owns twitch for free
okay it costs you nothing instead of you
paying five bucks a month you pay
nothing but it counts as a paid
subscription for us so you can Google
how to subscribe to twitch Prime and
it's very easy it takes almost no time
cost you nothing and we get a little bit
of money so that's great stuff I'll talk
to you on the bonus show and I will see
you on my next twitch livestream
Wednesday at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time